KIP SCHAUER: All right, welcome.
My name's Kip Schauer.
I'm from Denver, Colorado
over in the United States.
How many people have
been to Colorado before?
One, all right-- two,
all right-- three.
Well, great.
You're all welcome to
come to Colorado some time
and come enjoy the skiing
or the nice weather we have.
I've really enjoyed
my trip to Milan.
This was the first time
I've ever been here.
I've been to Rome, and
Florence in Venice before.
So thanks so much for
having me over here.
So we'll spend the
next 35 minutes--
and I'm going to save a
little time for questions
at the end-- talking about
Google's media story,
so media and entertainment.
I was hired three
months ago by Google.
I've spent the last
10 years at Aspera.
How many people use
Aspera if you're
in the media and entertainment
world moving large files?
OK, most people would.
So then IBM acquired Aspera.
So for the last three years,
I was over it at IBM also.
So today we're, going
to talk about media,
Google's strategy in the
media, and then we're
going to dig into the online
platform called Anvato, as well
as the machine learning.
You might have already
gone to a few sessions
on machine learning.
And I'll talk to
you about how we're
going to be applying it in the
media and entertainment space.
So a little
background, everybody
knows that media
consumption is changing.
Obviously, on my phone here,
I can launch an application,
watch video content right here.
How many people were
watching video right
before they started this?
Just about everybody, right?
I read a statistic that, every
single day, 57% of people
watch video on their phone.
And my question
to that was, what
are the other 43% of the
people doing with their phone
if you're not watching video?
I mean, everybody
watches video today.
And some of the videos even
just start to play right away.
So if you're watching YouTube,
or Facebook, or ESPN or any
of your sporting channels, the
videos will just start to play.
So the idea is, how do you make
sure you get the right video
content to each of us?
And you have to be
able to get it any time
to any different device.
I've got two teenage boys.
And to get them to sit
down and watch a TV show,
I don't remember the
last time they did.
If it was, I'm sure it was
just a movie that was recorded.
One of my sons has
built this big computer
with two different monitors.
And I don't know if he has
a split brain or something.
But one, he keeps YouTube
and video channels up,
so he can be watching TV while
he's usually playing a game,
or doing his homework,
or something like that.
So the way we're
consuming content
has changed dramatically.
And then the other thing for
you take somebody like my son
is, how does he get to the
content that he wants to watch?
So he's into paintball.
I don't know if they
have paintball here.
But you run around and shoot
each other with paintball guns.
And there's actually a
league in North America.
So there's a professional
group of paintballers
in North America.
And they have a
championship game.
And you can actually pay a
company that livestreams it
like $5.00 a month to be
able to watch those games.
I mean, you start
to think about that,
and what it opens up for
the possibility of everybody
is being able to watch video,
live video, livestreaming
video for whatever hobby, or
interest, or special concept
that we have out there, and be
able to consume it on my phone
while I'm at a conference,
be able to watch it at home
potentially on a TV,
or on your computer
have two different
monitors going.
And you can consume the content.
So everybody that's in the
media and entertainment world,
you know that the trick is
getting it to every device now.
So then the next
step is, how do I
use data to drive what
content's being pushed?
And how do I personalize it,
so that we each are consuming
the video content that we want?
"House of Cards," I'm
not sure how popular
that show was over here.
It was a Netflix show.
But they used data
to figure out who
was going to watch the series
before they launched it
by running different
types of trailers,
and testing them, getting all
that data back, analyzing it.
And then it helped them
launch "House of Cards."
And it became a very,
very popular show.
A couple of the other
things that are interesting,
the amount of content
now that's available
is, how do I get my content seen
if I'm on the other side trying
to produce the content?
There's over 400 hours
of video uploaded
to YouTube every minute, so
just massive, massive amounts
of content being uploaded.
And then with machine
learning coming out,
people are thinking-- well,
machine learning a little bit,
but also reality TV,
and the YouTube-type
content or Facebook-type
content that's all reality.
I know, a few years
ago, everybody
was thinking that TV
shows that are scripted
that have actors and actresses
were kind of going to go away.
And the world was just going
to evolve into reality TV.
What's happened is actually
the complete opposite,
where today there's over
455 scripted TV shows.
That's over double what we
had just five years ago.
I was down in Los
Angeles two weeks ago.
And in Los Angeles, that's
where a lot of the--
they call them sound stages,
where they actually shoot
the TV shows and film them.
And right now, every
single sound stage
is full, both on the
Universal lot, Disney, Fox.
They're renting them out,
because there's so much
new content being produced.
And the reason is, is
because you can get that
to every one of your
consumers without just having
to go through one
of the big channels
to distribute your content.
So it's exciting.
In my eyes, this is exciting.
Because it means there's
new content, better content,
more targeted content.
And it allows us to
personalize the content that's
being created and get
that to the consumer.
I'm not going to spend
much time on this,
because I'm sure
you've already attended
some of the other seminars.
But the investment in
Google's Cloud is amazing.
For video customers, content
distribution networks
are critical.
Being able to stream your
video and have a quick user
experience are absolutely
imperative to getting
good-quality video.
So today, you can use Akamai.
There's Limelight,
Level3, Fastly.
There's quite a few
content distribution
networks available.
And Google, last year, opened
up the CDN that YouTube runs on.
So the performance that
you get on YouTube,
the scalability of
YouTube, is now available.
So for a video
content publisher,
you're going to have
another option of a content
distribution network.
It's mainly been internally
consumed by the YouTube team.
So it might not have all
the bells and whistles
right now that you
would expect if you're
used to a commercially-facing
content distribution network.
But it's definitely
ramping up quickly.
So if you're using a content
distribution network today,
you're looking at
moving over to Google,
you'll want to look at Google
as a possible CDN provider
for your video content.
Obviously, I think everybody
heard in the keynote,
we have the applications that
run over a billion users.
So that brings us back to
media and entertainment.
Where is our focus?
So in kind of step
1, we have customers
that just want to lift and
shift their applications
over to the Cloud.
Over there, you might be using
just the compute environment.
You might be using the storage
environment, as well as
the content
distribution network.
So this morning, I
met with a customer.
They thought that
they wanted to run
on top of our video
streaming platform.
But it really turned
out, they had already
built everything they needed.
And they were just going to
need to lift and shift it
up over onto the
infrastructure platform.
So when you're working through
media and entertainment
challenges, you'll
find that, oftentimes,
what you've already built
might move over onto the Cloud
pretty easily and then just
be able to take advantage
of the different CDN options.
So we can definitely help
you move your applications
over to the Cloud.
Then in the middle,
basic over-the-top
app-- so Google acquired
a company called Anvato.
And I'll talk at a deeper
level on Anvato back in July.
That can provide you an
end-to-end over-the-top
solution.
So if you're looking at
launching your own application
and you need video content
in there, we'll go over that.
Re-engineering the workflow--
so if you have a workflow where
you might be able to scale it
up quicker if you're running
on the Cloud, we have people
that can help you figure out,
how do I move it
over to the Cloud
and then be able to scale it up?
And then the third
area that's obviously
receiving a lot of attention
is the machine learning
and, how are we going to apply
it into our video products?
Or how can you take that
Video Intelligence API
and apply it to
your own content?
So these are kind
of the three areas
that we're really focusing
on from a Google perspective
on the media and
entertainment market.
So Google's commitment to
the media and entertainment
market--
I had been in the media
and entertainment market
for the last 10 years.
Obviously, you know
that Google's YouTube.
And you kind of think of that.
But they've acquired
a product called
ZYNC in the rendering engine.
And they also support many
of the largest companies
doing the big, animated movies.
Anvato is a over-the-top
broadcasting solution.
And I'm going quick
on this, because I
have additional slides on them.
Intelligence, we're just
starting the intelligence
phase.
That's definitely,
in my opinion,
we're at the ground level.
And customers like you are going
to help define the best ways
to use this technology.
Monetization, so if you're
playing back to your videos
and you can add
the ads in there,
obviously, that's how you're
going to start to make money.
And then Google acquired
a company called Widevine.
Widevine is one of
the DRM solutions.
So there's about three different
Digital Right Management
solutions out there.
Google owns Widevine,
YouTube, Chrome, obviously.
So this is kind of
our 360-degree view
of media and entertainment.
So really quick,
for anybody that's
into 3D rendering out there,
we have an application.
So if you're using Maya or
Cinema 4D, Houdini, or Nuke,
those are applications
that look like this that
allow you to create 3D models.
We have created a plug-in.
And you can't really read
this through the projector.
But it's the coolest,
quick way to use the Cloud.
So when you've
finished your model
and you've done all
your coloring, and all
your frames, and
all your rendering,
there's a pull-down
menu right here
that tells you your options
for cloud rendering.
And it gives you, how
many cores are there?
And then you literally
just type in a number
for the number of
computers you want
to have spun up in the Cloud.
And it'll tell you
your cost right there.
We took care of all
the rendering costs
on the back end, so you don't
have to have special rendering
engines.
And when you hit Go, it will
package all your content up,
send it up to the Cloud,
do your full render,
and then bring it back down.
So "The Jungle Book" was
done by a company called MPC.
And they used the Google Cloud.
They did not using
ZYNC, because they
have their own big, custom
workflow for rendering.
But the amount of compute to
do some of these very, very
high-end rendering projects
is kind of mind boggling.
But 41 years of
compute time they
were able to do in
just over two months.
So what does this
allow the artists
in the animation team
that's working on it?
It gives them more time.
It allows them to
spend more time
working on the fine details
and just continually iterating
on the product, so that they can
deliver a better product to us.
So that's the power of the
Cloud around rendering.
So anybody that's in the
rendering portion of media
and entertainment, definitely
find your local Google
salesperson.
We have worked with
all the major studios.
We have what's called
MPAA certification.
So the major studios have
approved the Google Cloud--
so some really amazing
stuff we're doing
in the rendering area of it.
So now I'll switch
gears into Anvato.
Anvato is the company Google
acquired back in July.
And it's designed to be sort
of an end-to-end over-the-top
workflow to help you
if you're putting video
on your application.
You know, like at the
beginning of the show,
if you're pulling up
your sports application
and you need to
stream your video,
or if you're developing to
be able to stream to, say,
over Chromecast or
an Apple TV and you
need to be able to play
your video content back
on any of those formats, Anvato
will be able to help you.
Some of the customers, NBC
is the largest broadcaster
in North America.
And that's one of
our big customers.
Univision is Latin America, one
of their largest broadcasters.
Anvato was North America only.
So we're starting to work
with European customers
now that we have the
support of Google
and have been able
to expand the team.
So we can definitely
support you.
We can set up web meetings
if you need to on Anvato.
So what does Anvato do?
Again, sort of the complete
end-to-end workflow.
And I'll dive into it
each little section of it.
And we'll go through each one.
So livestreaming,
so you always have
to have some sort
of hardware to be
able to capture
the video signal.
But it's a software-based
encoding engine.
And you can deploy it either on
premise where the cameras are
and then move the
data to the Cloud,
or you can just deploy
it in the Cloud.
And you can capture
either what's
called baseband video coming
directly out of the camera.
Or you can bring in a
previously-encoded signal
for a live transcode.
So what does it look like?
Over there is where you're
capturing your content.
You're bringing it in
through the Anvato.
And it's just a
commodity hardware device
running our software.
And then you can go straight to
a content distribution network,
so the CDN.
And then you can stream
out either in HLS format.
And we're now releasing DASH,
if you're familiar with DASH.
It's another option
for streaming video.
And then the ads
all tie into it.
But I'll talk about
that in a second.
If you have a third-party
encoder already,
meaning you're encoding
your video already
and you want to send
it to the Cloud,
so that we can trans code it
into all the different flavors
and then deliver it
out over your CDN,
we can run in the Cloud also.
So you really have two
options for the way
you run the Anvato software.
So when that live signal--
and when I'm
talking live, I mean
we're watching a newscast
or a sporting event.
Anvato actually broadcast
the Super Bowl back in 2014,
so millions and millions of
people watching the same video.
That's the power of Anvato.
But then live to
[INAUDIBLE] means--
so that live signal is coming
in, I'm going to capture it.
And by capturing it, I can
then use that to post it out
onto social networks.
I can push it to
other online sites.
So being able to capture
it as it's being broadcast
will save you a step.
You don't have to wait
until the broadcast is over
and then have somebody
transfer it to you.
You can capture it right away.
So then people say, well,
as it's going along,
I might need to cut
out advertisements.
Because sometimes
you can't advertise
what's going out over
air on your phone
or on your mobile devices.
So you might need to
change the advertisement.
So there's a cloud editing
tool that makes it really,
really easy to cut ads out.
And then you can
also quickly grab
little snippets of highlights.
And you could use
that to post it
onto YouTube, Facebook,
Twitter and start
to send little bits of your
video out to your social media
quickly.
So this is the architecture.
It looks exactly
the same as before.
It's just now you're
doing your capture
and your editing in the Cloud
as you receive the content.
And then you can
also send content out
to the premium
syndicators, so over here
like Sky and all
the big broadcasters
here that need to
receive your content.
We have over 141
profiles set up worldwide
to receive the
content, because even
North-American broadcasters
send the content worldwide.
So those are already set up.
They're automated and makes it
easy getting the content out.
So video encoding-- so
once I have this video
and I need to get it into
all the different formats,
transcode it, we take
care of all of that.
Whether you're doing
the set top delivery,
or going to a Chromecast,
or going to your phone,
we can take care of that.
We can also work
with video overlays,
embedding the captions,
putting in at the bottom
there what are called
[INAUDIBLE] markers.
Those are the markers, as the
video content's going along,
it'll trigger ads to be played.
So when it's creating the
video, so that it plays it out,
we take into account
kind of everything
you need to do with that video
and make sure it's ready to go,
so that you can send it
out through your content
distribution network.
So syndication, I already
mentioned it just a second ago.
But this is taking the
content now that you have
and sending it out to all
the online players that
need to receive your
content, so that then,
somebody that's
subscribing maybe to a Hulu
or even Netflix, you need
your movies up there.
So you send it up to them.
And then they'll be
able to play it there.
So we syndicate over 1.5
million minutes a month
on behalf of the customers
that use our content.
And that's going to
all the leading portals
around the world.
So we have an OTT store.
This is not just we're
going to build a store where
you can do quick subscriptions.
It's more tying
into applications
where you need to, like,
authenticate against the cable
subscription.
So if you're a
sports app, and you
need to make sure that
somebody is paying for a cable
subscription like with
the TV Everywhere,
this will help you tie
your application together
with a subscription service.
And then dynamic ad insertion,
so ad insertion at the server
side is what Anvato does.
There's obviously
client-side ad insertion.
But to plug it into
the server side,
you can do it right
within the Anvato stack.
So again, you can put ads on
Apple TV, Chromecast, Roku,
any VAST--
V-A-S-T-- compliant
third-party ad servers,
so the DoubleClick server.
There's other servers out
there, like FreeWheel.
We can pull from many
of those ad servers.
And then generating
the analytics
is obviously key, getting
the feedback for what ads
are playing, and the completion,
and the click-through rates.
So the one thing
with server-side ads
I like to point out is
it's a little smoother user
experience.
Because it's not getting there,
having to go grab the ad,
pull it back in.
So when you're playing video,
the server-side ad insertion,
it's already baked
into the video stream.
And it'll just play right out.
So then the player itself,
Anvato won't make a player.
The actual skin, that's up
to you and your developers
to make it look and brand
it however you want.
But what Anvato players the
back-end SDKs and the APIs
that you're going to use, will
allow you to have that player
and be able to play
it on any device.
It does really fast startup.
And it'll insert the
ads we've talked about.
It does both adapt
to bitrate streaming.
And it can do Virtual
Reality, VR stream.
So if you're going to
develop your player,
we give you all
the back-end tools
that you need to be able to pull
the content, play the content.
You just need to develop the
application and use our APIs.
And then there's a
reporting dashboard.
There's a few changes going
on with the reporting.
Now that we're part of
Google, Google obviously
is very concerned about what
data is being collected.
So Anvato is just lining up
with the Google Analytics Team
and making sure the feedback
that we get within the Anvato
platform matches up with the
feedback that Google collects,
so a great reporting
engine as part of it.
So a couple examples--
so that's the stack.
That's the wheel.
But what are a few things
you can do with it?
So by being able to migrate
off of a satellite truck,
going up over satellite,
hitting the data center,
going to the service
bureaus, and then back out,
you can now go from the Cloud.
You have your encoder either
on-site or in the Cloud.
You send the livestream there.
You stream it out
to all the devices.
You can then syndicate
it from the Cloud.
So all of the sudden, your costs
of the truck and the satellite,
you don't need that anymore.
The real key, though,
that I've found
is making sure you have enough
bandwidth between the venue
and getting to the Cloud.
And over the last two
years, almost every venue
has been putting in more
and more bandwidth, which
is going to allow this
to occur kind of anywhere
is what I'm seeing.
So big cost savings if you're
broadcasting content looking
to move it over into the Cloud.
And then a live
linear channel, so
if you're broadcasting all day,
you need to have a schedule.
And we create a schedule.
Because with digital
rights, you're not always
going to be able to broadcast on
your phone or out over the top
the same content that you're
sending across onto the TV.
So you can quickly
replace content
that you don't have
the rights that you
want to have the rights to
or with a different show
that you have the rights to.
So it's the quick, easy,
adaptable, live, linear
streaming programming that
is also part of Anvato.
And then this is where it's
kind of exciting what's
coming around machine learning.
Because now, if I
can personalize this
with a pool of
content, then everybody
could start to get
their own shows.
And it's not just one show
going out to everybody
using the same application.
So this is one of
the areas that I
think is going to benefit
greatly from machine learning,
and being able to take all
the feedback from people that
are watching your channels,
and be able to provide
different content to them.
So shifting gears from
Anvato, virtual reality
is an area that Google's
invested in heavily.
For anybody that was at
NAB, which is the big trade
show in Las Vegas back in April,
Google will have a booth at IBC
over in Amsterdam.
I'm guessing a lot of
people here go to IBC.
So we'll be back at IBC.
But this camera was at NAB.
It's really cool.
It's about that big.
You take the picture.
And then we don't
build the camera.
But what Google does is
they built the software--
it's called Jump--
that allows you to upload--
I think there's 34 cameras--
and upload all the content.
And then it does the stitching.
So if you're in VR,
you can do that.
And then anybody that saw
the release the other day,
Google announced VR, like,
180 instead of VR 360.
Because 360 allows you to
look all the way around.
But if you look
back there and you
have a lot of cameras shooting
the content, all of the sudden,
you see everybody making the
movie or making the content.
With 180, you can
look around this way.
But you're only seeing what the
movie makers want you to see.
So I think it's--
I haven't-- this is
just from what I read.
But I think it's a way of
trying to say, you know what?
Let's adopt a technology
that is really cool,
in terms of being able to
pan around in the video,
but not allow you to go back
and see how it was being made.
So VR 180 just was
announced a couple days ago.
And I'm sure cameras
like this will figure out
ways to upload it to
Jump and then just render
the front half of it.
Daydream-- so the
goggles, so that you
can look at the VR experience.
These are the goggles
that Google creates.
And then kind off of
products back to the core
Cloud that I think is probably
the most interesting part.
If you kind of have built
already everything that
I've showed you today, BigQuery,
the cloud-based analytics--
so as we start to
run machine learning
against the archives
of all the video
that we own, and we start to
pull out metadata, and more
metadata, and more metadata, if
you can get it in to BigQuery
and then start to be able
to run analytics on it,
I think that's going to
be where the power is,
combining the machine
learning with the analytics,
and being able to
pull out queries of,
I need video with this actor
or this actress in here
over the last five years,
and be able to quickly
pull all that content out and
create new content with it.
So BigQuery is our enterprise
warehouse for this large data.
Spotify uses it.
I think you've
probably seen this
in some other presentations.
But the reason I
like to point it out
from a media and
entertainment perspective
is sometimes you're
asking simple questions.
One of the questions
I read about online
in terms of Spotify was, what
are just the top 10 songs that
played in Spain for October?
And it was taking
them 44 minutes
to get the answer back on that.
When they moved
over into BigQuery,
that frame went
down to a minute.
So then you think about
the business analyst
trying to decide, what are we
going to advertise in Spain?
What are we going to
do for the next month?
If they can ask more
questions of the data
and get the responses
back quicker,
obviously, it's
really going to help.
So BigQuery is that
platform layer that I think
is going to help media and
entertainment customers.
But it's part of the
basic Cloud, not an add-on
like Anvato, that was acquired.
So what's the next wave?
We've all been talking
about machine learning.
And so everybody,
I think, has seen
that there's the five APIs
that are available today.
So the speech ones, working
on grabbing that text out
for closed captioning, and then
taking that closed captioning,
turning that into metadata
that you can search,
and then also
translating it into all
the different languages
is, obviously, a big focus.
And then the Cloud
Video Intelligence API
is going to be used quite a bit.
So what we did is we took
the video supply chain here
and came up with a
few of the concepts
that we're working on
to plug into Anvato.
So today, the machine learning
is not built into Anvato yet.
But this is what we're
working on for future versions
of the OTT.
So a couple that I
like to highlight,
like in Cloud Editing--
I hope machine learning
doesn't replace all the jobs,
and that it allows us to
display more content--
kind of back to my first
comments, which is,
there's more content
available, because there's
more ways to consume it.
And I can see
exactly what I want.
So I was down at NASCAR, one
of the race series in the US.
But basically, think about
Formula One over here.
If your favorite
driver or favorite car
doesn't come in the top
three or so of that day,
more than likely, if
you log on that night
and you don't watch the race,
there's almost no content
available to watch.
Because somebody took all the
video that was shot that day
and made a couple really
cool highlights of the race.
But that means, my
favorite driver,
I can't see any
content about him.
But every one of those cars
has video cameras on it,
one probably on the driver now,
usually one facing forward,
a camera facing backwards.
So it's not that we didn't
capture the content.
It's that we didn't have
enough editors to go around
to edit every single one.
Well, imagine if you could
bring all that content in right
at the end of a race, run it
through a machine learning kind
of a cloud editing intelligent
clipping, so it was very quick.
And for every
single race car, you
could produce a five-minute
clip of the races.
Well, that's a lot.
Because, as editing,
you would have
to spend a lot of time looking.
But if you can train it
on what's interesting,
when it made passes, when it
went into the pit stops, all
the things that you might
want to see about the race,
imagine you could then have--
let's say there's
40 cars in a race--
40 different clips.
Maybe you could charge
people a small subscription
to go in and be able to view
all the clips at the end
of my favorite driver.
So I could click on it, watch
the video, pay a little bit.
Or it's ad-supported.
Maybe there's ads.
And now instead of everybody
just watching one highlight,
everybody can go
and pick and choose
which highlight
they want to watch,
because that's the driver
they're interested in.
And more than
likely, they're also
going to still go watch the
highlights of the overall race.
Because of course, we
want to see who can race.
So these are the things, in my
mind, that I get excited about.
Because all of the
sudden, there's
more content available,
easier to get to it.
It's edited.
It's gone through and
created better highlights.
So that's, in my mind,
a kind of forward
customer-facing implementation
of machine learning.
Under the encoding, if we can
do a better job with encoding
as the machine learns--
so if I'm an announcer
and I'm just standing here
like I am here,
encoding, you should
be able to squeeze this
video down pretty far.
Because there's not much action.
But as soon as action starts,
slowed down the encoding,
so you get a
better-quality signal.
So I think on sporting
events or events that
switch from almost no
action to a lot of action,
if you can have
machines watching that
and being able to encode
up and down, on the fly,
we're going to get
better compression.
And then there's a
whole host of other ways
we're looking at plugging
in the machine learning.
So again, the Cloud Vision,
you might have seen this.
So on stills, face
detection, pulling that out,
the logo, identification
labels, landmark OCR.
And then this was on
my highlights example.
"Chopped" is a chef TV
show over in the US--
but being able to
take machine learning,
beat it full of clips over the
hour, put them in, and say,
give me a five minute
highlight for "Chopped."
There's some shows.
Discovery, they
shoot up in Alaska.
The crab fishermen
are out there.
I think I've heard, they shoot
like 500 hours or 1,000 hours
of content for every show.
Because they have so
many boats going out.
And being able to run it
through machine learning
and be able to help create
more personalized highlights
is going to definitely be a
use case for machine learning.
And then the one that
everybody's still
trying to figure out and
how to do a better job
is contextual ads
and micro-segment,
tagging those videos
using machine learning.
So whatever's
playing in the video,
can you pull out related content
out of the video, specifically?
And with these
Vision APIs, we're
going to be able to do that.
So the last one, the
closed captioning
I talked about a
little bit-- so being
able to take the
speech-to-text and then
be able to turn
that into metadata,
so that you can search the
text and be able to find
the content that you want.
So machine learning, it's
definitely in its infancy
right now in this industry.
Those APIs are available today.
There's some good
tutorials on it
if you want to start
to learn about them.
And then if you're interested in
the Anvato software or the ZYNC
software, definitely contact
your local Google rep.
They can get in touch with us.
We can do meetings with
you and help you out there.
So with that, I've got a
few minutes for questions.
Thanks so much for your time.
Any questions?
Does anybody speak English?
I hope you do.
So I'll be back here if
there aren't any questions.
But thanks so much
for your time.
And enjoy the rest
of Google Next.
[APPLAUSE]